la imagen debajo muestra la gráfica de
como una función de x completa el
enunciado con base en la gráfica de la
función aquí tenemos la gráfica y nos
hacen algunas preguntas este es el eje y
el eje vertical y este es el eje
horizontal el eje x inicialmente cuando
x crece y espacio vamos a ver esto
inicialmente es decir al principio
cuando empezamos con el eje x en 0 y el
eje x va aumentando qué pasa con ya
bueno vemos que ya disminuye o decrece
entonces inicialmente cuando x crece y
decrece
la pendiente de la gráfica es igual a
espacio para toda x entre x igual a cero
y x 3 entonces entre x igual a cero y x
igual a 3 cuál es la pendiente bueno
cada vez que nos movemos una en la
dirección de x nos movemos hacia abajo
en la dirección de y nos movemos 1
negativo en el eje y aumentamos una la
dirección de x y nos movemos 1 negativo
en la dirección de iu así que nuestro
cambio en yes sobre nuestro cambio en x
es la definición de pendiente es en este
caso nuestro camión y es 1 negativo y
nuestro cambio en x es 1 la pendiente es
menos 1 sobre 1 esto es igual a menos 1
o 1 negativo y lo vemos en la gráfica
cada vez que x aumenta en 1 y disminuye
en 1
a partir de x 3 el valor de la función
de espacio cuando x crece entonces
empezando en x igual a 3 vemos que ya
crece o se incrementa cuando x se
incrementa mientras x se incrementa ye
se incrementa o crece así que ya crece
cuando x crece la pendiente de la
gráfica es igual al espacio para x entre
3 y 5 para x entre tres y cinco cuando x
se incrementa en 1 que se incrementa en
3 que se incrementa en 3 si x se
incrementa en 1 y como la pendiente es
igual al cambio en yes sobre el cambio
en x aquí la pendiente es igual a 3 el
cambio en el estrés y el cambio en x es
para x / x igual a 0 y x igual a 4 el
valor de la función ya es vamos a ver
que hay aquí menor o igual que mayor o
igual que o igual a cero así que para x
entre 0 y 4 el valor de la función ya es
menor es menor o igual a cero y por
último aquí dice para x entre 4 y 8 el
valor de la función es bueno vemos que
ya es igual o mayor que 0 vamos a ver
que no hayamos cometido ningún error
vamos a verificar nuestras respuestas
ok todo está bien